Today is a historic day for Croatia
and for the European Union.
Nearly nine years since
you applied for membership,
after six years of negotiations,
the Accession Treaty of Croatia
to the European Union
is ready for signature.
Croatia is set to become
the 28th Member State of the Union.
Welcome to the European Union!
The signing ceremony was
the crowning of a very long process
that started on 3rd October 2005.
It took a number of years to accomplish,
so, finally, when the signatures
were put on our Accession Treaty,
that was symbolically and practically
the end of a very, very long process.
After the Accession Treaty is signed you
acquire the status of permanent observer
and you can participate
in almost all the working bodies
and the Councils, all the ministerial
meetings and European Council meetings,
and, of course, the world of the Council
is now fully open to you.
It has been an extremely beneficial
and fantastic experience
to be able to sit in the meetings
of the Foreign Affairs Council
and the meetings
of the General Affairs Council.
Also my colleagues are
in those of Ecofin
and the Agricultural Ministers Council
and, of course, the Prime Minister is
in the meetings of the European Council.
Although we don't have a vote
until we are full members,
we have everything else,
we have the possibility of hearing
what people are saying,
we have the possibility of being here
when decisions are being made,
we have the possibility
of debating and discussing
and expressing our opinions
the same as everybody else.
With every enlargement we need new staff
to come and work for the EU,
so in view of the upcoming accession
of Croatia to the EU,
the European Personnel Selection Office
last summer started
selection of Croatian staff
in different fields.
We are running selection procedures
for general administrators,
for translators and interpreters,
and for assistants
in the field of project management,
law and communication.
By 1st July we will have selected
about 360 Croatian staff
to come and work for
the EU institutions.
The Council prepared well
for Croatia's accession
and creation of the new unit
started a year before Croatia joined.
Croatia entering the EU
is a big thing in our country
and us being here is really exciting,
taking part in the whole process.
It is a very good feeling
that our language
is now part of the family of languages
here at the Council
and that the Croatian language will
now be the 24th language of the EU.
It is a great honour
and it is very exciting
to feel part of
the whole project of the EU.
When Croatia got candidate status
and we started accession talks,
the number of journalists grew,
there are between 8 and 10.
I travel from Zagreb to Brussels
once a month, sometimes more often,
but when we become a member
of the European Union,
Brussels will be our second capital.
Institutions are adapting to the fact
that we, as Croatian journalists,
are here and we have questions that
are not only about enlargement anymore,
but about all the different issues
and portfolios.
Our hopes for the future
are high, of course.
For a couple of hours on 1st July
we are first going to enjoy
the beauty and the miracle
of our membership,
then it's back to the hard work,
because the work in the EU never ends.
We really do feel at home
around the Council tables
and it's a very, very good feeling.